نبدا صباحنا اليوم بنقاش حول تطبيق اصبح
كالهواء الذين تلبسوه بين الاهل والاصحاب
والاهم في العمل فمن منا لا يستخدم
الواتساب الذي يبدو ان رنه واتساب الشهيره
لم تسمع بعد اليوم في بنك مرجان ستان
الامريكيه الشهير حيث فرض احد اكبر البنوك
الامريكيه غرامه على موظفيها الذين
يستخدمون التطبيق او اي منصات تواصل
اجتماعي مع العملاء فبحسب التقرير ان
البنك فرض غرامه قد تصل الى مليون دولار
على الموفق الذي يخالف هذه القواعد
الجديده البنك الامريكي كان قد تعرض
لغرامك كبيره من لجنه الاوراق الماليه
الامريكيه بعد تحقيقات تخص الاتصالات
مماثله بالعملاء عبر منصات التواصل ويعود
ذلك الى ان هذه اللجنه الامريكيه المتخصصه
تفرض على البنوك تتبع الاتصالات الرقميه
للموظفين الخاصين بها ما يعني انها تعرف
جميع المكالمات التي يقومون باجرائها
[موسيقى]
عندما يتحدث عن المليون دولار هي غرامه
تعد الاكبر تخص شركه ماليه الا اما ده وما
هي حدود التعامل ماليا عبر واتساب وارسال
معلومات ماليه عبره
اذا كان عدد سكان كوكب الارض 8 مليار شخص
ففي عندنا احنا على التطبيق واتساب 2
مليار اااه حساب شغال بشكل شهري
بالنسبه للتطبيق واتساب واستخدامه في همم
المعاملات الرسميه من حيث الشركات او
البنوك اا البنوك والشركات لها سياسه خاصه
في استخدام جميع وسائل التواصل الاجتماعي
بشكل عام همم بحيث انه الشركه او البنك
بيخاف من همم تسريب المعلومات والبيانات
اللي موجوده همم
الموظفين لذلك بنلاقي انه في بعض البنوك
فرض همم اللي هو
غرامه ماليه
يعني المعلومات هذه يرسلها موظف البنك الى
العميل يعني هي معلومات ماليه خاصه
بالعربيه في هذه الحاله الى مادها تطبيق
واتساب كتطبيق لماذا هو امن جميل جدا الان
المحادثات في واتساب مشفره عن طريق اللي
هو التشفير التام خلينا نتخيل انه اذا انا
بدي ارسل رساله واتساب من تليفوني
بيكون هو عباره عن القفل الشخص اللي بده
يستقبل هذه الرساله همم بيكون جهاز يعني
انا بتكلم الان على الديفايز هو معه مفتاح
هذا القفل لكن هذا التشفير همم غير كافي
لانه الشركات تخسر من الثورات التي تظهر
بين الفنيه والاخرى على هذه التطبيقات على
سبيل المثال همم لنفرض انه قام شخص
باستخدام واتساب من خارج المتجر مثل
الواتساب الذهبي او تجيبي واتساب وهذه
التطبيقات غير امن لانه الاشخاص اللي
قاموا بالتعديل عليها قاموا بالتعديل
عليها على عن طريق اللي هو الريبرس
انجنيرنج يستطيع نقوم باضافه اكواد
الا تكبل حريه الشخص يعني اليوم عندما
نتحدث عن واتساب اصبحت ليست وسيله ترفيه
وسيله تواصل اس ام اس فبالتالي الا تتعدى
بها كذا قرارات الشركات على الافراد
وحرياتهم بصراحه اللي حدث او اللي جعل انه
هذا
الاجراء يصير انه في عام 2021 اعلن واتساب
انه سيشارك جميع معلومات همم مستخدم مع
باقي منصات همم او منتجات شركه شركه همم
هو في الحقيقه مش اعتداء على حريه ال-
الاشخاص او الموظفين لانه احنا اذا بدنا
نتكلم عن تطبيق مراسله والتطبيق همم ليس
للاعمال علما انه في عندنا نسخه همم
واتساب بزنس يعني لكن همم لكنها غير مهنيه
في التواصل مع الاشخاص اللي بتتعلق
بالبنوك وهمم وارسال المعلومات الحساسه
والتي يمكن همم اعتراضها من خلال هجمات
الامن السبراني
[موسيقى]